[Musique]
ils l'ont promis en 2012 ici la fin de
notre mandat 250 mille nouveaux emplois
et à nouveau en 2014 faire en sorte
qu'il soit créé 250 mille emplois à un
an des prochaines élections au québec on
en est rendus ou dans cette promesse de
créer 250 mille emplois on ne vérifie
[Musique]
alors qu'ils entament la dernière année
de leur mandat les libéraux ont atteint
79 % de leurs objectifs 197 mille
emplois de plus au québec depuis leur
retour au pouvoir en avril 2014
savez vous quelle est la province qui
créent le plus d'emplois dans le secteur
privé au canada c'est nous autres québec
par contre 197 mille emplois en trois
ans c'est pas un record entre mars 1999
et juin 2002 une augmentation de 311
1600 emplois avaient été enregistrées au
québec
à l'époque c'est le parti québécois qui
était au pouvoir poursuivre sans relâche
des efforts en vue de créer encore plus
lent vous allez peut-être demander au
départ le promettre 250 mille emplois
sur cinq ans est-ce que ça sorte est
temps que ceux de l'ordinaire mais on a
calculé depuis 1995 à tous les cinq ans
il ya en moyenne 250 3000 emplois de
plus au québec alors avec leurs
objectifs des libéraux vise ni plus ni
moins que la moyenne
si vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque
chose écrivez nous
[Musique]